the u.s surgeon general is calling covid
vaccine
misinformation an imminent and insidious
threat
that very stark warning was prompted by
a nationwide surge in cases of this
highly contagious
delta variant in a public advisory dr
vivek murthy says
false information shared on social media
is a serious threat to public health
that is driving vaccine hesitancy he
wrote that misinformation is fueling
fears
about possible side effects and led to
people to declare people to decline
covet 19 vaccines
nearly 56 percent of americans have
received at least
one vaccine dose u.s surgeon general dr
vivek morthy joins us now good morning
thanks for being with us good morning
what action do you want to see taken to
effectively stop this misinformation
well yesterday i issued a surgeon
general's advisory on health
misinformation
because i'm deeply concerned about the
impact this is happening on our health
and to be clear about what this is
health misinformation
is information that's false inaccurate
or misleading
about our health according to the best
evidence at the time
and as a doctor i've seen the impact
that this has had on patients i've seen
people struggle
to make medical decisions for themselves
and their families because they
they can't make sense of the conflicting
and often false stories you're seeing on
social media
but the good news is that there is
something we can do about this but it's
going to take all of us
working together individuals for example
can check their sources
before they share stories online is it
coming from a scientifically credible
source
and if you're not sure don't share but
we really need our tech companies to
step up here as well
because we know that so much of this
information is being transacted on
technology platforms
dr murthy in in our reporting earlier in
this broadcast
it came out that that this is actually
sourced back to a relatively few
uh initial sources do you have any sense
of why this misinformation is being
spread
well it's an interesting question and
there are several reasons but two that
i'll point out to in some cases there
are people
intentionally trying to spread
information sometimes for financial gain
or for political reasons or for other
reasons but we also know that
much of the misinformation out there is
often spread by people
who actually don't have bad intentions
there are people like me and you and
others who are listening today who might
see a story that they think is alarming
and they think
sharing it with their network might be
helpful to them they may not realize
it's false
and that's why in this advisory we we
physically point
to the steps that individuals can take
to pause before they share but it's also
why technology companies have
a really important role here to plan
identifying super spreaders of
misinformation
in stopping uh their activity and spread
the misinformation online
and it also helped in being more
transparent so we understand
just how much misinformation is being
transacted on these platforms and what
strategies are working to stop it
part of the reason why i think dr murphy
is so confusing let's start with los
angeles where now
even if you're vaccinated you have to
wear a mask
it just seems like the rules keep
changing because we're always told if
you're vaccinated
you're safe i call it my superpower it
protects you so why do
vaccinated people also now have to wear
a mask in los
angeles if supposedly you're safe with
the vaccine
so gail you're pointing to a really
important issue here this is we've seen
this as a challenge throughout this
pandemic
which is that as science evolves our
guidance has to also evolve
but if we're not able to communicate
that with enough context and clarity and
consistency then it can lead to
confusion
and right now with masks for example one
of the things we know is the science
tells us that if you are fully
vaccinated that's two weeks after your
last shot
your chances of getting sick and
transmitting the infection to somebody
else are low
that doesn't mean zero it means a low so
there are certain circumstances where if
you have
a lot of virus in your community around
you or if you are somebody who lives at
home with people who are unvaccinated
that you might choose
to continue wearing masks and localities
like la county or other
counties that are looking around and
seeing cases rising and seeing large
portions of people unvaccinated may
choose
to put measures back in place like mass
requirements
and that flexibility is okay but what
we've got to do is
consistently clearly and transparently
communicate with people about
what these rules are why they may be
shifting because otherwise it can be
very confusing
yeah i was very sorry to hear doctor
that you lost 10 members of your own
family to this
this to covet i'm sure you tried to
convince them to get the vaccine
so what do you say to people that just
don't get it
well gail first of all thank you and my
family members who
you know who have passed away
unfortunately due to covet
they didn't have a chance actually to
get fully vaccinated the vast majority
of them and i
think so often about things could have
been different if they did have a
vaccine available to them but for those
out there who are still
unsure of whether they should get
vaccinated number one i try
to listen uh to their concerns that's
something i was taught earlier in
medicine you don't judge people for
their beliefs you
you listen to them you try to understand
and then i also try to make sure that
they have access
to the information that science actually
guides us to understand about his
vaccine not the myths that are out there
in the midst of two-thirds of
unvaccinated people unfortunately
either believe or think or true but the
real facts and the facts are this
that these vaccines are our single most
powerful pathway to ending this pandemic
they've saved
thousands of lives already the benefits
of vaccinations certainly far outweigh
any rare risks that come with them so
as a doctor i urge people to look at the
data make the best decision for yourself
and your family
but know that they're saving lives right
now yeah i hear you and we will keep
repeating that information as often as
we need to thank you so much for joining
us this morning
thank you